ORDER WE WILL WE WILL PROCEED
WITHOUT A QUORUM TO GET STARTED
BUT I SEE THAT WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR HERE I WILL LET MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN COME 40% EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY ONE MEMBERS. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. OKAY. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB ONE
AB ONE RECONCILES A CONFLICT
BETWEEN FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
BY CLARIFYING THAT MILITARY
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO PAY ADVANCED
FEES FOR PERMIT APPLICATIONS TO
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT TOPS
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL THIS
IS A NEW LEGAL CONFLICT BROUGHT
ABOUT BY TWENTY SIXTEEN TRAILER
BILL WHICH CREATED A NEW FEE
FOR SERVICE PROGRAM REQUIRING
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF THE
COST TO BE PAID UP FRONT FOR
HAVE WAIST DEEP HOWEVER FDERAL
LAW PROHIBITS MILITARY FOR
GAUGING IN ADVANCE PAYMENTS THE
MILITARY OFFER OPERATE SEVEN
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND A TEN
YEAR PERMIT AT TEN YEAR. AND
IT'S IS NATIONAL STE THE
MISSION AND TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND HEALTH EXAMPLE OF
ONE OF THESE FACILITIES. I IS
ONE ON THE NAVAL BASE CORONADO
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY THE TRIP
CONSULT IT'S A VARIETY OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE STREAMS THIS
PERMIT IS CURRENTLY UP FOR IN.
THE MILITARY WILL STILL BE
REQUIRED TO PAY ALL REASONABLE
SERVICE CHARGES ASSOCIATED WITH
A PERMIT RENEWAL AND ALL OTHER
CHARGES APPROVED BY SPECIFIC
APPROPRIATION. OF FEDERAL LAW
HERE WITH YOU TESTIFIED SUPPORT
KERIS MY FROM THE UNITED STATES
NAVY. A VERY MUCH CHALLENGE
VERSE APPRECIATE YOU FITTING US
IN TODAY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. THE YES I'M A MEMBER SAID
EVERYTHING THAT I WAS IN A SAFE
PERFECTLY. APPRECIATE HIS
CONSTANT SUPPORT FOR THE
MILITARY IN THE STATE. AS HE
SAID THE MILITARY AND SEVEN
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES IN
THE STATE. ARE OPERATED UNDER A
TEN YEAR PERMITTED DTS THE AND
THE MILITARY HAS HISTORICALLY
PAID THE FULL FEE TO DGSE.
WITHOUT INCIDENT HOWEVER WE
RECENTLY DISCOVERED UPON
APPLYING FOR RENEWAL THAT A
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO THE BILL.
READ A 5% ADVANCE PAYMENT
REQUIREMENT BY THE DEPARTMENT.
FOR THE PROCESS FEES NOW THE
DISCREPANCY IS THAT. FEDERAL
THIS CALL LAW PROHIBITS US FROM
PAYING ANY FEES IN ADVANCE A
REIMBURSABLE WORK HOWEVER ONCE.
DGSE STAFF TIME CAN CAN POINT
TO THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE
TO PROCESS THE FEE. THEN WE CAN
PAY FOR THE COST PERMITS. AB
ONE IT AND SET CLARA IS THE
FACT. SO WHAT IS. AND THANK THE
AUTHOR AGAIN FOR SUPPORT. OKAY
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
CASKEY IS. I OTHER AGO SEE
THAT'S THE KIND OF LOVE. WOW
IT'S HERE FOR THIS THAT'S EVEN
MORE MANY FASTER CHAIR HAS
ANYONE ELSE HOW YES YOU ARE.
BUT REALLY THIS AT ALL. A
OPPOSITION CONCERNS. OKAY WELL.
THE SENATOR SAID IT BEST YEAH.
QUESTION STARTS NOW ALL RIGHT
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT
WE WILL WITH THE SECOND WE HAVE
THE NEXT SENATOR HERE. AND WE
DO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOU BE
ARE YOU CIVILIAN SIDE IS AT YES
NO INCOMING AFFAIRS RIGHT
GOTCHA OKAY FOR ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I'M. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE'LL WE'LL TAKE A BILL UP
ONLY. WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
QUORUM BUT I. PERSONALLY
RECOMMENDING AYE RECOMMENDATION
MISCHIEF YEAH. OKAY NEXT WE
WILL. YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN US YES. EXCELLENT. YEAH
BUT I KNOW YOU KNOW I'M ALL
RIGHT THAT'S IT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CENTERS THE PHONES AND- THANK
YOU AND MISTER CHAIR AS YOU
KNOW OUR VIRUS BEING OVERRUN BY
LETTER OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
BEING FLOODED BY WASTE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES CAN'T AFFORD TO
CLEAN UP WHAT IS HAPPENING
TODAY. AB TEN EIGHTY WOULD
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S ON THE
FOREFRONT OF REDUCING POLLUTION
FOR SINGLE USE PACKAGING AND
CERTAIN FOODS ARE SAYS BY
ABOLITION COMPREHENSIVE GOAL OF
REDUCING OUR WAYS FROM THESE
ITEMS 75% BY TWENTY THIRTY
THREE FORCE REDUCTION COMPOSED
IN. I CLEAN AND CLEAN SPECIFIED
IN TERM RECYCLING RATES. THE
BILL NOW WITH DIRECT HOW
RECYCLE TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS
TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS TO SOURCE REDUCE
THESE ITEMS TO THE EXTENT
FEASIBLE AND ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE FULLY RECYCLABLE ARE
COMPATIBLE BY TWENTY THIRTY
SINCE YOU LAST SAW THE BILL
WE'VE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH ADMINISTRATION AND
BUSINESS STAKEHOLDERS AND
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS THE RECYCLING RATES
THE BILL ARE NOW MATERIAL
NEUTRAL SO AS TO NOT PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS. AMONG
MATERIAL TYPES AND DO NOT
RESULT IN A CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN UNTIL PENALTY UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN INCLUDES VALUE IN
POTENTIAL AND USE MARKETS FOR
MATERIAL IN EVALUATING
TRANSITIONING AT THE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS THE ROLE OF THE
RETAILERS HAS BEEN CLARIFIED
UNDER THE BILL. A SLANG
CALCULATION FOR WASTE REDUCTION
SURPRISED BY HOW WE ALL SORTS
REDUCTION CHECKLIST INCLUDES
CONSIDERATION SUCH AS PRODUCT
PROTECTION SHELF LIFE AND
SUBJECT AS SUGGESTED BY THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE CLARIFIED
THAT NO REGULATIONS DEVELOPED
AND THERE'S BILL WILL CONFLICT
WITH REGULATIONS OR LAWS THE
BILL ALLOWS FOR EXEMPTIONS FOR
BUSINESSES. WE'VE ADDED AN
INDEPENDENT STAKEHOLDER PANEL
TO CONSULT AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS. TO CAL RECYCLE
MINIMUM STANDARDS. IS CHOOSING
PHARMACY. INNOVATION HAVE
NOWADAYS AND WE'VE ADDED THE
ABILITY FOR CAL RECYCLE TO
CHARGE APPROVED REGULATORY FEE
FOR THE COST OF THE WORKLOAD
IMPROVING THE PROGRAM. WHICH IS
HOW SIMILAR PROGRAMS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT ARE FUNDED. MOST
RECENTLY WE ALSO AMENDED BILL
TO PHASE IN PRODUCERS. UNDER
THE BOTTLE BILL IN TWENTY
TWENTY SIX TO THE SPELL. SUCH
THAT WE CREDIT THEM FOR
INVESTMENTAND WORK THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE AS PART OF
THE PROGRAM UT STILL ENSURE
THAT THEY EVENTUALLY ARE
SUBJECT TO REQUIRED RECYCLING
RATES AND REGULATIONS. WITH
THESE CHANGES AMONG OTHERS THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
AND DOW CHEMICAL COMPANY ARE IN
SUPPORT. THERE ARE ALSO A
NUMBER STAKEHOLDERS IT BECAME
NEUTRAL THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL PROCTER AND GAMBLE S.
C. JOHNSON CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. TECH NECK THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CONSUMER
HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
THIS BILL IT HAS ALSO BEEN
TAKEN OFF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE A JOB
KILLER LIST. I RESPECTFULLY.
KALI AS YOU KNOW. SOMETIMES
SOMETIMES YOU LOSE YOUR OWN JOB
KILLER. DEAN GETS JUST JOKING
OF COURSE BUT THANK YOU OF
COURSE THE CHAIRMAN YOUR STAFF
AND MY STAFF AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE GONE THROUGH
SO MUCH TO TRY TO CREATE A BILL
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
EVERYBODY CAN SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY
WE CAN'T GET EVERYBODY TO
SUPPORT IT BUT I THINK WE'RE ON
A PATH. IT TO GET OUT MOST
PEOPLE'S BRIAN AND I THINK IT
WAS A LOT OF WORK BY OF COURSE
YOURSELF AS WELL ON THE
COMPANION MEASURE. AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU TREMENDOUSLY IN
ITS CENTER SKINNER AND HER
STAFF AS WELL. IT'S BEEN A LONG.
LONG LONG ROAD BUT IT WOULD
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS YOUR STAFF AS WELL. I
LET'S HEAR FROM YOUR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HIGHER MARIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GRISTLE CH AND WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND YOU CENTER ALLEN
AS WELL AS THEIR STAFFS. FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT'S GONE INTO
THIS REALLY APPRECIATE THE.
CONSIDERATION WHEN LOOKING AT
PACKAGING. WE'RE SATISFIED THAT
WITH THE OFF RAMPS PROVIDED AT
A VERY REASONABLE. AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE LOCAL GUIDELINES
FOR SOME LOCAL ORDINANCES. THAT
WE FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT A LOT
OF OUR COMPANIES ARE ALREADY
DOING A LOT OF THESE THINGS
THAT THE BILL ASKS. THAT THEY
CAN KEY DO SO AND SEND MARKET
SIGNALS THAT. THAT CALIFORNIA
IS HEADING THIS WAY AND IT WILL
ALLOW FOR A LOT OF OUR
COMPANIES TO. START DOING WORK
AND SUPPLY CHAINS IN
MANUFACTURING TO GET TO THE
GOALS. I'M SAID ABOUT THIS BILL
SO. WITH THAT WE ARE IN CHARGE
FOR THE BILL THANK THE AUTHOR.
MISTER CHAIR. OF THE COMMITTEE
MARK A PRAYER I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES. WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF FOR THE DILIGENT WORK
THAT. THROUGH THE TIME LEADING
UP TO THIS HEARING TO YOUR
STAFF. THE STAFF OF SENATOR
SKINNER AND ALL THE EFFORTS BY
ALL THIS ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS.
WE SENATE AT A HEARING WHEN SB
FIFTY FOUR WAS IT WOULD IN ITS
FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE HEARING.
THAT THIS IS A BIG DEAL THIS
THIS CONTINUES TO BE A BIG DEAL
AND WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. AND WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU MARK.
OKAY LET ME JUST POINT OUT AND
WE HAVE FOLKS WANT TO ADD ON
SUPPORT TO LINE UP THAT I DO
WANT ONE OF THE SCOTT SMITH
LINE USED TO HAD A CAR CYCLE IS
HERE. I KNOW THAT SOME SOME
MEMBERS VERY WELL I WANT. TO
FOR. QUESTIONS ASK ASKING
QUESTIONS. SO LET ME LET ME
ALSO TAKE THIS MOMENT TO JUST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ALLEN HERE SENATOR BATES
PRESENT HIM CENTER DOLLY HERE.
SENATOR HILL SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR STERN WHAT CASKEY. OKAY
SO WE GOT A QUORUM THANK YOU
AND WHEN WE NOT GIVE FOLKS THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU WANT TO ADD ON
SUPPORT. YEAH THANK YOU MARK.
CAPTION THE CLOSE OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE HERE
IN SUPPORT WILL ALSO ON ECHO
THE COMMENTS ABOUT THE
TREMENDOUS WORK OF THE STAFF
AND THE AUTHORS OF THESE BILLS
THANK YOU. GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON
BEHALF OF NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND CLEANS HE'S
LOVING COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. LUIS ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. EMILY RASH ON BEHALF
OF HELP HERC ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIANS DON'T SUPPORT AS
THE WITNESS SAID THIS IS A BIG
DEAL THANKS. DO YOU REMEMBER
STARK OFTEN HEAVILY CALIFORNIA
CITIES WHEN I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IN THE CHAIR AND
CENTER SKINNER AND HER STAFF
AND EVERYONE STAFF FOR THE
GREAT WORK. THAT'S OUR BEHALF
THE DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT. YOUR CREDIT WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. IT IS FOR
X. ABOUT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
IN SUPPORT. ON FLOOR NUMBER ON
THAT HEALTH DEREK IS HILL THE
BAY AND THE COMPASS COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. BRAND ALSO
SEE A CUP CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
SELECT US HERE ON BEHALF OF
STOP WASTE CALIFORNIA PARTS DUE
TO CANCEL NATIONAL START ACTING
COUNCIL IN CITY OF SANTA MONICA
AND LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT. ONE
OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT A BY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. AND ONLY
SERVER ON BEHALF OF THE POOL IN
SUPPORT. GARCIA WITH C. ARM SEE
OUR IN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
SERVICES AND READING WAYS IN
SUPPORT. CAN THE ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE SEVENTH
GENERATION. ENDS OF THE LA
RIVER AND PRESS CANCER VENTURE
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER AUTHER CNN STRONG
SUPPORT. I'M SORRY SOME HAVE
WILD W. IN SUPPORT. JOHN
KENNEDY RC RC ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. CARE MORTENSEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. KELLY JENSEN ON BEHALF
OF RECOLOGY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS TRENT SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
NOW NEUTRAL MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS. IT'S OUR JOURNALISM
ELECTION ANHEUSER BUSCH NOW
NEUTRAL WITH RECENT AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. READ ADDISON BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL CONSERVATION
CHORDS IN STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR RIDGE
DISTRIBUTORS AND FOREVER LABS
NO NEUTRAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. ANYMORE THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION ARE MOVING
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH. REMEMBER RJ SETTLEMENT
THIS ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION NOW
NEUTRAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THE AND WITHOUT THE BEER. OKAY
MISTER LIBERTY BELL OKAY WELL
WHY YOU MIGHT AS WELL TELL US
AGAIN TELLS HIM. JUST REMIND
EVERYBODY OF THE- ALL THE HARD
WORK OKAY ALL RIGHT. YES NOW
THERE CAN'T POSSIBLY BE ANYBODY
HERE. I MEAN AFTER ALL THIS
HAPPENED THIS SUMMER. MY GOOD
FRIEND MISTER ROBSON. WHAT DO
YOU HAVE TO TELL AS WELL. I AM
A- I RELUCTANTLY HAVE TO GO SO
I'M HERE ON BEHALF THE GLASS
PACKAGING IS TO. WE'VE WAITED
IGNORED THIS BILL NOT IGNORED
IF WE'D STAYED OFF THIS BILL
FOR A WELL KNOWN WE STAYED OUT
WE SET OFF THIS BILL FOR A LONG
TIME BECAUSE IT WAS A BILL.
THAT WAS DESIGNED AND BY ITS
TITLE WAS THE PLASTICS CIRCULAR
ECONOMY. YOU KNOW REDUCTION ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY OR TWENTY
NINETEEN OR WHATEVER AND WE
THAT WAS WE'RE FINE WITH THAT
YOU KNOW THE THAT THERE'S
TWELVE FINDINGS IN THE BILL
THERE'S TWELVE FINDINGS IN BILL
EIGHTY. ART INDICTMENT ON
PLASTIC. AND THE GLASS
CONTAINER INDUSTRY OR THIRTY
YEARS HAS BEEN COMPETING
AGAINST CONTAINER TYPES IN THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY. THAT THAT
THAT YOU KNOW AND WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS AN UNFAIR LEVEL YOU
KNOW WE WE'VE BEEN PAYING
PROCESSING FEES AND SUPPORTING
THE BOTTLE BILL FOR THIRTY
YEARS. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PACKAGING THAT IS NOW THEY USED
TO BE IN GLASSES AND OTHER
PRODUCTS. HE SAID THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO START LEVELING
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR THESE
PACKAGING MATERIALS. FOR A
PACKAGE. FOR A CLASS PACKAGE
THAT WE ALREADY BELIEVE IS A
CIRCULAR PRODUCT. DOESN'T
BELONG IN THIS BILL. AND THEN.
AS THIS BILL EVOLVED OVER TIME.
AND ESPECIALLY AFTER LAST WEEK
WHEN ALTHOUGH THE WHEN THE
REGULATORY FOUR FORTY IN THE
FIELD FORTY WHEN IN THE BILL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE SEE THIS
BILL IN WITH EVERYTHING WE IN
ON YOU LIMIT ALL THE WORDS THE
WORD. ASPECT THROUGHOUT THE
BILL TO NOW WHEN I READ THE
BILL ICE I READ. THE GLASS
PACKAGE TO DESERVE IT IS A
SINGLE USE PRODUCT UNDER THE
DEFINITION BILL SO EVERY EVERY
TIME I READ CEILINGS PRODUCT
ALL I READ IS CLASS. SO THIS
BILLS NOW A GLASS BILL. IT WAS
A PLASTIC BILL NOW TO CLASS
BILL. AND THAT'S THAT'S. BEEN
MY CLIENT READS IT AND- IT'S
UNFORTUNATE. THE GLASS TAYLOR
IS 1100% RECYCLED A GLASS
BOTTLE CAN BE A GLASS BOTTLE.
AS LONG AS IT'S HANDLED
PROPERLY. WE HAVE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CLASS
MANUFACTURING CALIFORNIA ARE
MAKING BOTTLES AT FORTY THREE
AND A HALF PERCENT RECYCLED
CONTENT. 43% THE MANDATE IS 35%
THERE'S SOME BOTTLES COME FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD
PROBABLY COME IN AT 506070% WE
PAID WE PAY FEES TO SUPPORT THE
RECYCLING TRUST WITHIN PAYING
FOREVER. WE PAY WE ALREADY PAY.
A SECONDARY PROCESSOR TO MOVE
TO PROCESS OUR GLASS WITH SOME
OF THE THINGS YOU GUYS WANT.
FOR ALL THESE OTHER COMPUTER
TYPES WE ALREADY DO THERE'S A
GLAD THERE'S A SECONDARY
PROCESSING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE SUPPORT. BY
BUYING THAT PRODUCT FROM. THE
GLASS CONTAINER MANUFACTURES IN
CALIFORNIA MADE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND NINETY THOUSAND TONS OF
CLASS LAST YEAR. I'M NOT NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND TONS
GLASS LAST YEAR IN EIGHT
HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND
TONS OF GLASS. WITH BACK INTO
EITHER GLASS CONTAINERS OR
FIBERGLASS SO WE- WERE
BASICALLY IT 89% REAPS. YET
WE'RE GONNA GET PUT INTO A
REGULATORY FEED PROGRAM. IT IS
UNDEFINED IN LIMITED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE YOU'RE GONNA GIVE
IT ALL TO. CARRY CYCLE LET THEM
FIGURE IT OUT IN THERE'S A LOT
OF THINGS WITH THAT THAT. WE
HAVE ISSUES WITH THIS. DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
LIMITS ON THAT ON THAT THE
AUTHORITY. YOU KNOW THEY. POWER
CYCLE GIVES TO THIS. WHAT IS
REASONABLE. I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
IT'S A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES RESULT
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES RESULT FOR
THEM TO COME TO MANAGED
PRODUCTS. AND I KNOW. BECAUSE
I'VE TALKED SAN AROUND TALK TO
A LOT AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING YOU SAID TO ME.
THERE'S JUST A- THERE THERE WAS
A LAW THAT PASSED AND- I DON'T
KNOW IT WAS LIKE NINE. NINETY
FIVE IT WAS A HAZARDOUS WASTE
TOXINS IN PACKAGING Là. IT WAS
ALL ABOUT THE COMMITTEE NOW
SEATS WERE ALL ABOUT. TOXIC TO
PLASTICS AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PLASTIC CONTAINERS
AND THINGS. BUT THE FIRST THING
HOW THE DEPARTMENT **** DID
COMING OUT THE GATE. AFTER THAT
WAS A POLITICOS COME AFTER
CLASS. DON'T KNOW WHY SO.
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE THAT'S
THAT. THAT'S THE FAITH THAT WE
HAVE IN IRAQ. FORTUNATELY. WE
FOR NO VOTE I MEAN WOULD RATHER
WE'D RATHER YOU START FROM
SCRATCH AND TAKE CLASS OUT OF
THIS AND THEN PUSHES FORWARD.
ON THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE MY
ONLY MY ONLY COMMENT ARE. GLASS
WAS ALWAYS IN HE BILL AND- WE
DO SPECIFICALLY EXEMPT ALL THE
FOLKS WHO ARE. SUBJECT TO THE
BOTTOM BILL ALL THE WAY UP TO
TWENTY TWENTY SIX IN. AND
THAT'S WHY FOLKS LIKE THE MERRY
BEVERAGE. YOU KNOW A VERY MAKE
MEMBERS OF DROPPED OPPOSITION
AND- I'M FRONT TWENTY SIX IS
THE ONE THAT SENT THAT SETS
LIMITS ON THE REGULATORY STUFF
SO. YEAH THERE IS NOT IS NOT
SOME HAPHAZARD. NOTICED I BUT
WE STARTED WE STARTED WITH THE
BILL. EVERYBODY WHO SO AT THE
END OF THE PROCESS YOU HAVE A
BILL WHERE THE GLASS CONTAINER
INDUSTRY THE 100% RECYCLED
PRODUCT IS OPPOSING A BILL.
THAT THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL IN THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY AND ALL THESE OTHER
PEOPLE THERE NOW NEUTRAL ALSO
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT A
TON OF PEOPLE OF A GLASS ARE
ACTUALLY. I WILL BE WORKING ON
YOU ROBSON RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
GET YOUR- WE'RE GONNA GET YOU.
OKAY YES SIR. CENTER ALLEN THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THANK YOU JOHN
HERE ON BEHALF THE GROCERY
MANUFACTURERS SAID. I'LL ECHO
THE KNOWLEDGE MEANS OF YOUR
BOTH YOUR WORK IN STAFF WORK
AND YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER AND ON THIS BILL
ANNOUNCED PROCESS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DO WE DO STILL
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF CONCERNS THAT
REMAIN I I'LL TRY TO NARROW IT
DOWN TO JUST TO. IF POSSIBLE
AND THE FIRST BEING THAT YOU
KNOW WE BELIEVE THE BILL STILL
LAYERS AND QUANTIFIED
REGULATORY PROGRAM ON TOP OF
ARE BROKEN AND BROKEN RECYCLING
SYSTEM. AND IN ADDITION KERN
SAID THE POSSIBILITY. PRIVATE
EYES TO A SYSTEM THAT COULD
COULD CONTINUED UNDERMINED OUR
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR
PUBLIC RECYCLING SYSTEM WE
THINK YOU KNOW WE THINK WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT WE
THINK WE CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE.
PAYMENTS BASED IN IN THAT AREA
AND THEN SECONDLY THAT YOU KNOW
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT THE BILL
STILL. A DOZEN ALLOCATE AND
FULLY SHARE THE RESPONSIBILITY
THROUGHOUT THE WASTE TO RESET
ST SYSTEM ON EVERY. BE IN IT
BOTH FASHION I THINK WE- ONE OF
OUR FOR. REMAINS COMMITTED TO
MAKING THINGS RECYCLABLE
COMPOSTABLE. WE CAN'T DO THAT
WE ARE DOING THAT AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO MAKING 1100% OF
SINGLE USE PACKAGING.
RECYCLABLE COMPOSTABLE BUT
AFTER WE MAKE IT. YOU KNOW
THERE ARE OTHER PARTS OF THAT
WASTE STREAM. NOTABLY CONSUMERS
AS WELL AS AS OTHER PIECES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TURNING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THERE'S NOTHING TO
COMPARE TO PRECLUDE US IN THE
BILL FOR MAKING THAT PRODUCT
RECYCLABLE COMPOSTABLE. AND
ONLY TO HAVE SOMEBODY THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN. THROW IT
AWAY OR FOR. A WASTE ENTITY ARE
HOLLER TO LAND FILL IT FOR
ECONOMIC CONSIDERATIONS ARE
REASONS AND SO. WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
THIS BILL WITH YOU ALL WITH
BOTH THE YOU WE REMAIN
COMMITTED WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE
THAT ARE YOU KNOW THAT THAT CAN
A MAN AND WORK ON THIS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE BUT BUT AGAIN. WILL
END AND WANTING TO MAKE AN
IMPROVEMENT TO THE SYSTEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
STRUCTURE NECESSARY TO SUPPORT.
WHAT WE HAVE. CENTER YES SIR.
AND THE ARTS NAM WITHOUT GMP
LOCAL SEVENTEEN AN- HOUR. AT IN
BEHALF OF THE GLASS WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S
ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED OF US
RIGHT NOW.IT'S AN INDUSTRY
THAT'S BEEN DECIMATED BY
OUTSOURCING AND VARIOUS OTHER
THINGS WE LOOK AT THIS BILL AS
A POTENTIAL JOB KILLER IN OUR
INDUSTRY. AND NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THE
NATION THIS BILL COULD
POTENTIALLY HURT COULD GLASS
JOBS ACROSS THE NATION. AND THE
REASON WHY I SAY GOOD GLASS JOB
BECAUSE THESE JOBS ARE HIGH
PAYING HIGH WAGE UNION JOB. AND
THE WAY THAT THE BILL BE
WRITTEN WE'RE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH SUPPORTING SO WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES AND. THANK YOU MISTER.
MEMBERS DON CAP HE ON THE-
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATIONS HIM
TEARS UNFORTUNATELY AS STILL
REMAINS OPPOSED. I'M AS YOU MAY
BE AWARE SEEM TA REPRESENTS
PACKAGING AND- A COMMODITY
MANUFACTURERS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED
BY THIS BILL NOT ONLY PLASTICS
BUT ALSO GLASS PAPER. A AND
METAL CANS AS WELL AND
CERTAINLY THE C. P. G.
COMPANIES THAT THAT WOULD BE IN
SCOPE. WE CONTINUE TO BE
CONCERNED FOR THE REASONS THAT
THE PRIOR SPEAKERS HAVE RAISED.
ADDITIONALLY RAISE CONCERNS
RELATED TO THE EMERGENCY RULE
MAKING AUTHORITY FOR AMONG
OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. A
DE FEES STUDYING WHICH LEMONADE
CIVILITY FOR MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT. A STAKEHOLDERS
REGARDING THAT FEW SETTING. AS
WELL AS OTHER CONCERNS AS NOTED
ABOUT. FOR STRUCTURE HI BROAD
SCOPE OF AUTHORITY.
ADDITIONALLY ABILITY TO SET UP
THE POP SCHEMES. AS WELL AS HAD
VANCE DISPOSAL FEES WHAT HAVE
YOU POTENTIALLY AS PART OF THE-
SYSTEM. SO IT MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED BUT APPRECIATE DONGLE.
AND FOR THE CONTINUING THANK
YOU. BY MISTER HEWITT ON BEHALF
OF THE FOOD INDUSTRY WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS A
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE LET ME
OKAY JUST A PROCEDURAL THING
FOR MY COMMITTEE. I MEAN I
COULD I GUESS THE FOLKS WHO
SPOKE IN SUPPORT OR SAID
THEY'RE GOING OFF NEUTRAL DID
NOT GIVE THE LONG RANGE OF
REASONS AS TO WHY THEY- HADN'T
THE VARIOUS ACCOMMODATIONS WE
MADE INDUSTRY. SO AS TO MAKE
THE BILL MORE PALATABLE I'M I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE LIKE HERE
EVERYONE'S KIND OF INDIVIDUAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL BUT
THAT I COULD BE FAIR FOR US TO
HAVE A MORE ROBUST.
CONVERSATION ON THE PRO SIDE
WHERE THE NEUTRAL SIDE TO KIND
OF FULLY EXPLAIN. THE TYPICALLY
PEOPLE JUST KIND OF VOICE OF IN
OPPOSITION BUT I SO I JUST WANT
TO KIND OF THROW OUT TO
EVERYBODY. WHAT'S FAIR HERE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'LL GET
IMPRESSED. WE'VE GOT ALL THIS
IS CONCERNED. I'VE GOT A LITTLE
A FULL PAGE OF FOLKS CAME OFF
OF OPPOSITION BECAUSE IT. WE'VE
AND HELP GET THEM THERE SO I
JUST WANT TO KIND OF. I'M HAPPY
FOR FOLKS TO RAISE A COUPLE
CONCERNS BUT I LIKE TO KIND OF.
I WANT TO KEEP THAT FAIRNESS
ISSUE IN MIND IN TERMS OF HOW
WE- MOVE THIS CONVERSATION FOR
YOU THAT. ALL THIS THE END BY
SAYING. UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE I THANK YOU
BRIDGES ARE MUCH. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KELLY ASTRA
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA REFUSE
RECYCLING COUNT. ON BEHALF OF
THREE OTHER. REGIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS WE HAVE MOVED
REGRETTABLY FROM. THIS
PARTICULAR THE REFERENCES TPR.
I WAS IN THE BILL BUT OKAY
RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HAPPY TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION I
DON'T WANT TO MONOPOLIZE WE
HAVE A CONCERN STILL OVER
INFRASTRUCTURE THE AUTHORS CAL
RECYCLES ON REPORTS ADMIT IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
MANDATES IN THE BILL WITHOUT
ADDRESSING INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S
THE BIGGEST GAP IN THE BILL WE
DID REMOVE JOB KILLER BUT WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED THE BILL.
IN SOME I MEAN TO LEARN. WE
WORK. ONLY WITH YOUR STAFF TO
REMOVE. SO YOU KNOW WE
APPRECIATE YOU TO WORK WITH YOU
BUT- WE STILL HAVE GREAT
CONCERN THANKS RISEN. MISTER
CHAIR OF MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THE COOKING AS FOR THE
HOUSEHOLD COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATIONS TO OPPOSE THANK
YOU. THAT IS ALL THE ONLY BE
HALF THE ALLMAN ALL I IT'S THE
CALIBER GRAIN FEED CALIFORNIA
SEAT IN THE EGG. SUCH A COMPANY
FARMERS SUPPOSED. JOHN MOFFITT
ON BEHALF OF WASTE MANAGEMENT
METHOD OPPOSE UNLESS MEANT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AB POP OUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
RECYCLING IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND I MANAGED. WHEN WAS THAT
FOUNDED THAT ORGANIZATION.
EARLIER EARLIER THIS YEAR.
MISTER CHAIR REMEMBERS ALL THAT
FILLED REPRESENT YES HE JOHNSON
WAS A MAKER HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS
WE OF GUN FROM A OPPOSED TO
NEUTRAL SO I'M ONE OF THOSE
TELL US ABOUT THAT. YEAH I KNOW
HOW I LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT. ALL I CAN SAY
IS A- LOT OF WORK. THAT WENT
INTO THIS BILL IS NOT A PERFECT
BILL BUT- BUT CERTAINLY.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN ADDRESS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE DEALING WITH AND
ALTES. BILLING WITH A VARIETY
OF OTHER ISSUES. THAT WE FEEL
AS THOUGH. IT'S IN A GOOD
ENOUGH SHAPE THAT WE WENT
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL SO. FOR
THAT THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
GOD. OF THE CHAIR AND-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER I'LL GONZALEZ.
AND NANCY'S SENATORS SKINNER'S
OFFICE. IS OF THE WILL WORK
VERY HARD TO GET TO THIS POINT
VERY MUCH SO. WE GIVE YOU A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT CENTER
SKINNER FOR A YEAR. YOU'RE VERY
HARD WORK ON THIS YES. SOARING
OR THE FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND I'M NOT HERE IN
OPPOSITION BUT I'M WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSAN LITTLE WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
JUST IN SUPPORT I'M SORRY MISS
THEM. THANK YOU FOR DIFFERENT.
DOUBLE BREASTED SUIT ELEVEN
RATE. WITH THE AMERICA WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS OPPOSE. OKAY
GREAT A LOT OF EXCITEMENT. NEW
NEWS IN VARIOUS WAYS SO THIS
MATTER I WILL I DO I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT. TO HI MY FRIEND FROM
THE US W. THE BILL DOES CALL
FOR INCENTIVES IN IN IN FOR IN
STATE MANUFACTURING AND A
DIRECT KERR CYCLE DEVOID
SHIPPING MATERIAL OUT OF THE
COUNTRY. WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK
TO AVOID IT I MEAN THE FACT THE
MATTER IS THAT THE BILL. THE
ULTIMATELY. WITH STRANGE TO ME
IS THAT WE HAVE SOME FOLKS IN
GLASS AND A CELL PUNCHED PEOPLE
IN CLASS INDUSTRY OF COME ON.
AND SUPPORTER OR NEUTRAL BUT IT
IS. THREE THAT WE GOT SOME
FOLKS WHO ARE RAISING CONCERNS
ABOUT A POSSIBILITY DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR PACKAGING MEETS
THE SAME RATES AS GLASS. TOM I
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE I'M
OPTIMISTIC I THINK WE'RE GONNA
KIND OF HELP TO. WORK WITH YOU
AND EXPLAIN HOW WE'RE GONNA GET
THERE BUT- YES AREA THIS IS
THIS IS WHAT WE WANT. ALL RIGHT
SO LET'S NOW OPEN THE FLOOR TO
QUESTIONS CENTER SKINNER.
CERTAINLY I WANT IT ENCOURAGE
THEIR TO BE QUESTIONS
INDISCRETIONS BUT I WANT TO
MOVE THE BILL JUST BECAUSE THE
ONE. WE GOT A SHORT TIME FOR IT
TO GO BACK TO THE FLOOR. AND I
WANT TO THANK MY STAFF AND
EVERYBODY REALLY WORKED HARD ON
THIS IS BEEN ENORMOUS.
UNDERTAKING THE- CERTAINLY THE
OPPOSITION CAN RAISE SOME
ISSUES LOOK AND I DO NOT%
QUESTION THEIR THEIR EITHER
ISSUES OF THE MTIVATION BUT I
THINK WHAT IS VERY WISE ABOUT
THE BILL IS THAT IT ESTABLISHES
ECONOMIC ADVISORY GROUP OF
INDUSTRY WASTE HAULERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHERS. IT DOES
NOT TRY TO WRITE ALL THE RAGS
WE DIDN'T TRY TO CROSS EVERY
TEEN DOT EVERY ICE SO THAT WE
CAN ALLOW THAT PROCESS MORE
STAKEHOLDER TO FIGURE IT OUT
THE END I THINK GIVEN WHO THE
AUTHORS ARE. IN JUST THE NATURE
OF OUR PROCESS THAT IF WE
REALLY FIND THESE FATAL FLAWS
THAT WILL AFFECT THESE IN WE
WILL COME BACK AND FIX IT WE
WILL SO ARE I'M JUST VERY VERY
PROUD THAT WE ARE. WE HAVE THE
HOPE OF MOVING THIS FORWARD
GIVEN OUR CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN
AND AS A COMMENT TO A WICKED
WHO MADE THE SAID THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THE NEW WAS
NEWLY CREATED THAT THEY
REPRESENT. AS AN ACTIVIST IN
BERKELEY IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES
WE USE CREATE MANY
ORGANIZATIONS TO SUPPORT OR
DIFFERENT EFFORTS AND AROUND
OUR FOR THE VERY FIRST IN THE
U. S. FIFTY FOR RECYCLING GOAL
WE CREATED BEFORE BERKELEY
FRIENDS OF RECYCLING. THE
BERKELEY INTO AGAINST WASTE ALL
KINDS WE HAD AT LEAST FIVE
GROUPS WITH DIFFERENT A FEW
DIFFERENT MEMBERS NEED TOWARD
BUT ANYWAY SO IF YOU HAVE A
WINDING IF ONLY FR THE FUNDING
YOU KNOW. HAD WE COULD JUST
EXPAND OR LIST OF HOSTED
SUPPORT OF THINGS ALRIGHT THANK
YOU MARCH THANK YOU VERY CENTER
FOR YOU CENTER. OKAY QUESTION
SIDE SO THERE ARE OTHER
CONCERNS. I DO WANT TO THINK
THAT THE AUTHOR FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK AND THIS REALLY HAS
BEEN SUCH A SUCH A GROUP EFFORT
AND WE WOULD JUST EXTRAORDINARY
STAFF ENGAGEMENT ON THIS AS
WELL. YOU KNOW I WILL SAY IT IS
PERSONALLY DISAPPOINTING THAT
WHEN WE'VE HAD SUCH AND- SUCH A
ROBUST PROCESS OVER THE SUMMER
THAT AS THEY SAY HAS HAS
GOTTEN. SO MUCH OPPOSITION OFF
TO HAVE SOME FOLKS CAN COME UP.
YOU KNOW RAISE CONCERNS SO LATE
IN THE GAME BUT- YOU KNOW WE DO
REMAIN REALLY COMMITTED TO
WATER WHICH IS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH EVERYBODY AND. AND SEEN
SEEN FORGET THERE BECAUSE IN
THE END OF THE DAY THIS IS.
SUCH AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE.
THE ISSUES KEEP GETTING WORSE
THE BOTTOM LINE KEEPS GETTING
MORE PROBLEMATIC BOTH FOR
CITIES AND ALSO FOR COMPANIES.
I AM WHO ANYONE INVOLVED IN
WASTE MANAGEMENT AND SO ON. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS PHONE NUMBER. SO I
THOUGHT YOU WANTED TO THE
REACTION TO SETTLE OKAY FIRST
OF ALL. YOU CAN CALL ME BY MY
FIRST NAME ANYTIME BUT IT'S LA
RANNA NOT THE REYNARD ARENA.
CHAMBER THE RETINA BUT ANNA IF
YOU'RE NOT IN OUR THANK YOU.
AND I'M SERIOUS ABOUT THAT AT
MY THE FIRST NAME BUT LET'S GET
RIGHT AT. I WOULD SAY THIS SOME
OF THE THOUGHTS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP I DON'T DISAGREE
RIGHT AND I KNOW THAT SENATOR
SKINNER HAS TALKED ABOUT WHAT
WE HAVE NEEDED ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAS SOME
COMMITMENTS IN THE FUTURE
THAT'S A THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM
WE'VE GOT A CHICKEN AND EGG
THING GOING ON HERE. AND WE
KNOW THAT IN ORDER TO CREATE
THE TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE TO
CREATE THE GOALS I MEAN IT AND
WE'VE SEEN THAT THAT'S WHY WERE
IN THIS SITUATION SO I DON'T
WANT TO. I DON'T WANT TO
SUGGEST THAT THAT WERE READY WE
WILL BE READY THOUGH YES THE
SECOND THING I WANT TO POINT
OUT IS. IT TO THE STEEL WORKERS
IF I THOUGHT FOR A MINUTE THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO JEOPARDIZE
GOOD UNION JOBS I WOULDN'T BE
HERE I ACTUALLY THINK THAT
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS BILL IS A
REINVESTMENT OF GOOD UNION JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA. A STATE WHERE WE
NEED THEM AND IT'S NOT ONLY
GLASS BECAUSE THE INCENTIVES TO
MANUFACTURE HERE BUT ALSO IN
RECYCLING IN THE ENTIRE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY PROVIDES US
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY CREATE
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WE
KNOW ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO BE
UNION JOBS. AND IN FACT I THINK
WILL ADD TO THAT THEIR GOOD
PAYING UNION JOBS THAT'S PART
OF WHY I AM COMMITTED TO THIS
BILL SO I UNDERSTAND THE FEAR
OF CHANGE AND THE FEAR OF LIKE
WHAT. COULD HAPPEN OUT OF THIS
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY. I WANT TO
ENSURE THE WORKERS THAT. I
DON'T SEE ANY ASPECT OF THIS
THAT WILL COST GOOD UNION JOBS.
AND THE GLASS IF IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO SIT HERE WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE COMPLETELY
RECYCLABLE AND THAT THEY CAN'T
SOMEHOW FIT INTO THIS.
RECYCLABLE GOALS YOU KNOW SO I
THINK I UNDERSTAND. THE CONCERN
WE HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR AND
WE'RE VERY CLEAR BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THIS HAS TO
BE. MATERIAL NEUTRAL AND I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING I
ALSO DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE. TOO MUCH OF A STRETCH FOR
GLASS TO. TAKES HIT THE GOALS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE DELAY TO
TWENTY TWENTY SIX FROM THE-
BARBELL. SO WITH THAT I AGES
WHEN ADDRESS SMALL CONCERNS AND
I RESPECT FELT WHY NOT SO OUR
MANAGER ACTUALLY. ON OUR VICE
CHAIR REQUESTED THAT WE HAVE
THE CAD ACCOUNT RECYCLE COME IN
AND JUST ANSWER THE QUESTION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU
IN MIND GEN THANK YOU I THANK
YOU OUT HAT'S ALWAYS TROUBLED
ME SERVING ON EQ. IT'S A GREAT
COMMITTEE VERY CHALLENGING AND
DOING GREAT THINGS AND THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU GUYS ARE DOING
ABSOLUTELY NO. EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO WHAT WE SEE GOING
ON IN THE OP. THE RECYCLING
WORLD BUT WHAT TROUBLES ME AS
WE CERTAINLY DELEGATE TOO MUCH
RESPONSIBILITY AND NOT ENOUGH.
BUT FAVOR A ROLE FOR
LEGISLATORS OUGHT TO OUR
BUREAUCRACIES THAT'S ALWAYS MY
PROBLEM IF IT COMES BACK TO US
BECAUSE WE REPRESENT ALL THOSE
PEOPLE OUT THERE ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE ISSUE. AND WERE ABLE TO
KIND OF FIX THINGS THAT DON'T
WORK SO NOTHING IN THIS BILL
TELLS US HOW YOU ARE GOING TO
ADDRESS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES. THAT ARE CRRENTLY
CAUSING THE CRISIS. ARE YOU
NEED SO MANY MORE EMPLOYEES TO
DO ALL THE F. IN A VERY SHORT
TIME LINE SOLD. HELP US
UNDERSTAND TO BEGIN WITH WE
HAVE A FEW SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
THERE'S A NEW FEET I
UNDERSTAND. SO THERE'S NO
STATUTORY LIMIT ON FEES AND I
LIKE TO GO THERE FIRST BECAUSE
EVERYTHING SOUNDS GREAT AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN IS COSTING. YOU
KNOW GAZILLION DOLLARS AND THAT
FALLS ON THE CONSUMERS AND ALL
THE PRODUCERS SO. YOU KNOW
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT ARE ARE
MAJOR ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE SOME FRIENDS SOME BOOKENDS
FROM YOU ON HOW YOU APPROACH
THAT THAT HAPPENED WITH THE BE
THIRTY TWO WHEN IT WENT TO. AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
THE I. A. R. B. THOSE ARE HUGE
ISSUES WE'VE HELPED ARE GREATLY
I THINK OVER THE COUPLE YEARS
TO REIN IN SOME OF THAT BUT-
I'LL START WITH THAT AND I. I'M
SORRY OUR TIME IS SO LIMITED
THAT LET'S LET YOU LEAST PUT IT
ON THE TABLE BECAUSE I THINK WE
NEED TO BE BACK HERE TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE- LET'S SAY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
ARE COMING. GOING TO COME OUT
OF IMPLEMENTATION. OF SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY COMPLEX AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M SCOTT SMITH LINE
DIRECTOR OF COVER CYCLE MAYBE
IF I COULD JUST START BY SAYING
APPRECIATE MANY COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE HERE TODAY CERTAINLY
THE APPROACH AS WE PERCEIVE IT
THAT HAS BEEN WORKED WORKED OUT
THROUGH THE LAST MONTH OF THIS
BILL IS ONE THAT MAXIMIZES
FLEXIBILITYOF COPLIANCE AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO THE DEPARTMENT
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS SOME OF THEM
LATER IN THE PROCESS BUT
SUBSTANTIVE NONE THE LESS THAT
ADDRESS. PRODUCT SAFETY FOOD
SAFETY THE MINIMUS AMOUNTS OF
DIFFICULT TO HANDLE MATERIALS
MATERIALS WITH UNIQUE
CHALLENGES SMALL BUSINESS
EXCEPTIONS OFFRAMP THE ABILITY
FOR US TO FORM A WORKGROUP THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY GROUP THAT
WILL MEET REGULARLY AND REPORT
BACK AND MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER WE SHOULD BE ADJUSTING
AND THESE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
IN THE BILL SO WE STRONG
SUPPORT THAT APPROACH I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THAT
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT TO
THE FEE THE FEE HAS A VERY
SPECIFIC PERFECT PURPOSE AS
OUTLINED HERE THE FEE IS TO
COVER THE REASONABLE COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
SO THERE'S NO ABILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. TO RAISE A FEE TO
SAVE STARTING TO INCENTIVE
PROGRAM OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT AND WE ARE GOVERNED BY THE
REGULATORY PROP OBVIOUSLY AND
ONE OF THE COMPOUND TôI
PROCESS SOMEONE NAZARIAN WARNED
US THAT THE BURDEN IS UPON THE
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS THAT ARE THE LEAST
BURDENSOME AS POSSIBLE AND
THAT'S THE STANDARD THAT. WERE
HELD TO WHEN WE SUBMIT
REGULATION THE WAY. SO THAT.
APPLIED WAS WITH RESPECT THAT
FEE AS WELL SO THERE IS NO CARD
LAUNCH THERE IS NO WE CAN SET
THE FEW WHEREVER WE WANT WE
HAVE. DEVELOPED REGULATIONS
THAT WILL. ACHIEVE THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE STATUTE THE
GOAL THAT NEED TO BE MET. WE
HAVE A PROCESS LAID OUT FOR OUR
TO DO THAT INCLUDING AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. AND
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
BUT ULTIMATELY THAT PEOPLE JUST
TO BE COVERED THE REVIEWS
REASONABLE. COST OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM. I
KNOW I HOPE THAT. AB THOUGH
THAT'S THAT'S THE LANGUAGE FROM
PROP TWENTY SIX I MEAN THAT IS
THE ROUTE THE REQUIREMENT ON IS
JUST LITERALLY JUST. THE
MINIMUM COST IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM. AND WE MUST DO SO IN
IN THE MATTER THAT'S THE LEAST
BURDENSOME AND THAT INCLUDES
ATTEMPTING TO MINIMIZE THAT FEE.
YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHO
WILL BE THE YOU TALK ABOUT
STAKEHOLDERS WHO THAT THE TABLE.
BECAUSE THE COSTS ARE
DETERMINED BY THE PRODUCERS SO
OFTEN THOSE AREN'T.
LEGITIMATELY A ANALYZE WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHAT IT COSTS TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM FROM THE
OTHER SIDE FROM THE BUREAUCRACY.
SO THE BILL HAS TWO PRIMARY
STAGES IF YOU WILL THERE IS AN
EARLY STAGE WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT WILL MEET REALLY
NEED TO GET SOME THINGS IN
PLACE SO WE WILL NEED TO
DEVELOP SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS DEVELOP PACKAGING
CATEGORIES DETECTOR THAT NEED
TO BE DONE SO WE CAN GET. THE
SORT OF THE LONGEST ON RAMP IF
YOU WELL TO THE PRODUCERS HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY INTO THE PROGRAM
BUT THE MAIN REGULAR. WELL
THROUGH AN EMPLOYER PLAN AND WE-
TAYLOR THIS BILL REQUIRES US TO
DEVELOP IN THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY
WAYS POLLUTION REDUCTION PANEL
ON THAT PANEL IS GOING TO BE SO
IT'S LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WASTE
MANAGEMENT. I'M FARMING GROUPS
PRODUKTER PACKED ACTORS.
DESIGNER AND RECITE AND THE
BILL REQUIRES US TO DO IT IN A
BALANCED WAY SO THAT WE MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A BALANCED VOICE
ON THAT PANEL AND THAT PANEL
NOT ONLY. HELP US. DEVELOP THE
REGULATE THAT ALSO. THAT WE
EVERY EITHER BASIS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT DUSTING THOSE
RECYCLING RATES THAT ARE
REQUIRED IN THE BILL I HAVE TO
SPEAK TO THE CHAIRMAN ON THIS
ONE IT WOULD BE NICE IF WE
COULD SEE A COMING BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE THOSE DRAFT
REGULATIONS AND HOW THE BAND
FORMED FORMATTED AND FORMULATED
WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE
THE ISSUES BROUGHT UP HERE
TODAY DON'T THINK EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS REALLY ON THE SAME
PAGE EVERYBODY WANTS TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM. OF THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO FEEL OUT THERE AN
ANTENNA CONSERVE TO SPEAK SO
MUCH OF IT IS KIND OF BIG MAYBE
THE WORK IN PROGRESS ISSUE SO
I'M GONNA WITHHOLD MY VOTE.
TODAY ON ONE HEAR MORE ABOUT IT
AND I KNOW OUR CHURCH AS WELL.
ALLEGEDLY FROM THAT. WAS FIRST
HEARD ON THIS SIDE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE. BUT I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL CERTAINLY FOR THE
PRODUCERS AND THE CONSUMERS.
THERE WE GET OUT OF. YOU KNOW A
BETTER HANDLE. ON THE IMPACTS
ON THE FACT THAT YOU WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL SINCE WE'VE HAD. SO
MANY ISSUES AND YOU ARE NOW
ACTUALLY. YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO DO A HECK OF A LOT
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE AND I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE A BETTER.
RESPONSIBILITY IN TERMS OF THE
WAITING PACKS CONSUMERS. AND
PRODUCERS. I WILL SAY TO FIRST
OF ALL I APPRECIATE THE VICE
CHAIRS COMMENTS ON THERE ARE
VERY STRINGENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING RIGHT
AFTER THE PLAN. AND I YOU KNOW
I KNOW THAT I THINK IT'S BEGUN
TO HAVE EVERYONE THE COMMITTEE.
AND I'M SURE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE THAT THERE WILL BE A
OF X. A LOT OF INTEREST IN.
MAINTAINING STRICT OVERSIGHT
OVER THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS. OF THIS BILL IF IT IF IT
PASSES AND. THERE WILL BE
THEY'LL BE A LOT OF. PLACE FOR
LEGISLATIVE HE GAVE ME SAY THIS
TERMINALIA. CERTAINLY FOR
ASSEMBLY. WHEN YOU SEE BY
LORRAINE. REYNA YOU YOU BOTH
HAVE BEEN VERY OPEN TO THE
PEOPLE TRIPS TRAIPSING THROUGH
YOUR OFFICE AND THREE ALIVE
SALAS. THIS WAY INTRODUCE BUT
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU TAKE ON
SOMETHING OF THIS MAGNITUDE IN
THIS HUGE IMPACT ARE THAT THAT
SOMETHING THAT YEAH THAT THAT'S
A CHALLENGE BUT THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT WE ASK FOR IT. YEAH
BUT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE I
MEAN WE WERE VERY CONCERNED I-THINK ABOUT THAT AT TO YOU AT
THE OUTSET. AFTER YOU WERE THE
NEW DATA SAID YOU KNOW HOW MANY
ITEMS ARE MADE FOR NEW BABIES
MATTER A MAJOR PRODUCTS THAT
WOULD BE OUTLAWED WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AND HE SAID
YEAH FULL THERE'S AN AWARENESS
AND AWAKENING THERE BUT MORE
USED TO BE DONE. YEAH THE WE
SAY YEAH AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I WILL SAY YOU KNOW WE HAVE
LANGUAGE ABOUT HEALTH AND
SAFETY. MAKING SURE THAT THE-
THERE'D BE ABSOLUTE NO. BE A
COMPROMISE ON HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS IN ADDITION IT'S
IMPOSSIBILITY AND IF THERE'S
LITTLE A PRODUCT THAT'S- IT IS
NOT A- VIABLE ALTERNATIVE. AND
THEN WE ALSO DO THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW EXCEPT INFANT. FORMULA
PACKAGING AND OTHER THINGS ON
THOSE LINES. I WILL SAY ON THIS
FEE ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT
UP. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY THAT. THE GLASS FOLKS WHO
HAVE DROPPED THEIR OPPOSITION
WERE SO ANXIOUS TO DO WE- MAKE
A KEY CHANGE WHICH WAS TO. IF
YOU'RE IN THE BOTTLE BILL. IF
YOU'RE THE CRP PROGRAM AND YOU
WERE MEETING YOUR RATES YOU ARE
EXEMPTED FROM THIS BILL. TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. I AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY WERE NERVOUS THAT
THEY WOULD BE YEAH DOUBLE
CHARGED EFFECTIVELY FOR. THE UC
OUR P. AND FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT OF SB
FIFTY FOUR TEN EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY. AND SO SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT THEM FROM ANY
POSSIBILITY OF THERE BEING COME
A DOUBLE CHARGE. WE'VE MADE IT
REALLY CLEAR AND THE BILL AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S PART.
OF WHY. SO MANY FOLKS ON THE
BAY BRIDGE. THE FACT EXCITED.
OTHER MOST FELLOW QUESTIONS
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION IF YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ON MEMBER RESPECT
LAST NIGHT OF THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH OKAY MOTION BY
CENTER SKINNER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER TWO
A. B. TEN EIGHTY. THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION ALLEN AYE ALLEN
AYE BATES. DOLLY HELLO. I
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN
STERN HIGHWAY CASKEY I CASKEY
AYE THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU EVERYBODY THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK EVERYBODY. WE
HAVE WE GOTTA TAKE UP ANOTHER
BILL YES. SO CAN I HEAR A
MOTION FOR A SELLING THEIR MAIN
SHINES AB ONE EIGHTY ONE. MOVED
BY ANIMAL CASKEY. US SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM
NUMBER WHEN AB ONE EIGHTY ONE
BY. I'M A MEMBER MIND
MAIENSCHEIN MISSION IS DO YOU
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE
AYE BATES. BATES OUTSIDE THAT
DOLLY. HILL HILL AYE SKINNER. I
STERN STERN I LIKE OWSKI KELSEY
I FIGURE VERY BIG STUFF.
RETURNS